OMER PERCHIK: Hey, I'm Omer.
I'm the Founder and
CEO of Any.DO.
Any.DO is the world's leading
task management application
for mobile devices.
Our mission is to turn every
day into a good day through
creation of day-to-day simple,
beautiful and fun life
management applications.
Creating an app is not just
having an icon in the user's
home screen.
It's about creating engagement
and getting the user to use
your app from different
parts of the OS.
That's why we integrated our
app deeply to the OS, and
created different ways for the
user to interact with our app.
In most cases, people think
about opening an app
just for the icon.
But in Any.DO's case, we deeply
integrated into the OS
in several ways.
The first way was to integrate
with widgets.
In the widgets, you can actually
see all of your tasks
that you have planned for today,
tomorrow, upcoming and
someday, but you can even
mark them as complete.
So just by clicking on one of
the tasks, you can choose and
you can mark them as complete.
The second type of integration
that we did in the active part
was to actually, in the
notification center, show all
the tasks that you have
planned for today.
And you can easily scroll
between everything you have
planned or add a new task.
We've seen that over 40% of
our users open the app not
through the icon, which means
that the integration with the
OS on the deepest level provides
a lot more engagement
than anything else.
So to sum up, the Android
platform allows us to do a lot
of things to increase
users' engagement.
We've managed to create an
experience in which the app is
so deeply integrated to the
device where you feel as if
it's part of the OS.
This allows us to create a great
user interface, a great
experience, and a better
usage from our users.
Thank you, Android.